[Music]
[Music]
mmm
[Music]
so
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your
everyday life hi i'm dan hayes and i'm
joined by my co-host dr greg
sadler today we're talking about doing
well
in a polarized society and this is stuff
that we probably
should have top of mind anyway but we
just went through
a very acrimonious election season
and a real nail-biter of an election
so i think it's it's particularly
helpful for us now to think about what
resources philosophy could
contribute to understanding our
situation
or to helping us cope with it what did
you have
in mind dan considering that it seems
like
no one really got everything they wanted
uh whereas the the great philosopher
jagger once said
you can't always get what you want but
sometimes you just might find
you get what you need um
outside of you know the good mick jagger
we have
this this feeling of um
divisiveness and polarization and
it is not really good for i'd say
our mental health to be constantly
living in this
uh that being the major overtone of the
entire
uh way that we look at the world it
becomes this incredibly
uh constant grading uh
fight and and constant like
uh stress upon you and it's it's not
going to
lead you to your best life and it's
probably not going to lead you to
uh treating others around you in the
best way possible
yeah you know things are so polarized
right now
and this has been going on for over a
decade
that you know on dating apps for example
people won't
consider dating somebody who's from the
opposite political party and and many
people are now are in ineffectively in
bubbles
in their social media where they they
have very few
connections or friends from the opposite
side
for myself as as like a registered
independent who doesn't belong to either
party but you know who
who strategically pivots against the one
that i think is
the biggest trouble at the time it's
been you know
something to see i i remember 10 years
ago i would try to get into discussions
on facebook with people
who i knew you know from from childhood
and
it always went badly when you'd point
out well you know
there's i wasn't doing both sidesism
right
i was i was saying well you know like
this point is is actually
quite correct but you're going too far
with it and man they
they so quickly they would say oh you're
you're one of them you're on the other
side
and you'd be like no no i'm actually you
know i'm trying to like
see things from from different points of
view and that is
something that is becoming more and more
difficult
to do i i would say um in in the
situation that we're in so
it's way worse today than it was ten
years ago or even five years ago
and not only are we being sorted into
silos from
our like the media and the social media
that we
tend to consume but we're also self
sorting ourselves and there's been
a large movement of people like
physically moving to places where
oh you are living with only people that
have
a similar outlook to you and so like no
longer is just
being neighbors and having to deal with
a community in which
that is a thing um that that brings you
into good relationships with
people that you happen to have different
political views
um where now it's like everyone that you
know
also has a very similar political view
and
i guess you've also seen this with a lot
of
uh christianity within the united states
where
on the churches themselves are becoming
incredibly paralyzed as well
um kind of to the detriment of the
church going populous if you think that
is something to
be beneficial yeah and it's i mean it's
not just
religious groups it's fandoms it's all
sorts of things
you know where uh matters are being
split down
the middle uh well or not necessarily
down the middle could be like you know
one third goes over this way and the
other two thirds goes over this way but
there's
there's definitely a chasm or a divide
that that has emerged i wouldn't even
say is emerging right it's there
and and we're living in it and it's one
of um
mutual distrust and misunderstanding and
a willingness
on on the part of some people to go
pretty far
in not just using rhetorical uh you know
techniques and and what we you know what
one could call verbal violence in some
cases you know using a lot of the words
that we're not going to use in a radio
program
um you know pretty routinely but to the
to the extent of physical violence and
intimidation
um if we don't get some sort of handle
on this
we're in real trouble as a
society and there's nothing that you
know i know a lot of people like to
think of america as being
exceptional um and there is this thing
called american exceptionalism but but
it does
it's not it's not a true thing you know
there's nothing to say that this
experiment that we have is going to last
another 100 years
and a lot of it will depend on whether
we can
be members of one society and
i don't want to say everybody gets along
as one big happy family or anything like
that
that's never been the case right and we
have some serious issues to
to grapple with and to to start
addressing uh but if we can't
form any sort of consensus that isn't
based just on wheeling and dealing and
and who has power at the time if we
can't
make any appeals to something that goes
beyond that that transactional way of
looking at things or that
us versus them way of looking at things
i think we're in real trouble and and
people
are some people are worried about that i
think a lot more people are worried
about what
what they perceive the other side to be
doing you know
or their own their own side not doing
enough um
i think more people are worried about
that i think it's a
really good way to kind of bring us to
one of the central thoughts
here in that feeling of alienation or
you know the state of experiencing
of being isolated from a group in which
you should belong or which you should be
involved and it feels like we are
not only being alienated from our other
countrymen
yeah um but we're also being alienated
from our government and yes one of the
big ways i see this
is that you know as a you know
represented democracy like early on you
know
the house was the chamber of legislature
which was supposed to at least at the
federal level
level represent the population
and you know at the very beginning we
had 30 000
people per representative and now it's
at
700 000 people per representative
and we haven't increased the size of the
house since 1912 it used to be a
rather um regular thing to do
congressional re
um apportionment um
and it's one of the things that's
enacted in the constitution that
allows the congress to increase its size
and we we just have failed to have the
political will to actually do that
and you know once we we don't feel
that we have a really good say in our
representatives
and then you feel that the the
government doesn't actually represent
you
or your things that you care about and
especially when you get to like
the big office you know with the
presidency you know
it can really turn into uh just
us versus every bad person that you can
possibly conceive of um as as your
booking man that you're going against if
they're not
the the person for you and this this
tribalism
that has brought us away from that
cohesive union
that uh yes they asked for the more
perfect union
yeah i mean i don't know that we ever
historically had
a great consensus going on right i think
that sometimes we've certainly had more
but there's certainly been more civility
and more willingness to
work with other people which i think i
think some people kind of found boring
you know
um it's an interesting thing that this
election
so many people did come out to vote on
both sides
well and even for you know like the
libertarians or
for some other parties as well it seems
like only the libertarians managed to
get
a significant portion of the vote this
time around as a third party
but a lot of people came out but they
came out
i would say mainly to say we can't let
those other people win
in the past when we had a lot more a lot
more consensus and compromise
i think a lot of people found elections
a bit more boring and didn't participate
as much so it's it's sort of you know
it's a it's a two-edged sword we
ideally we'd have everybody
participating you know because it is
important to have
people's voices heard in other countries
like for for example australia if you
don't vote you actually get a fine
for not voting here in america there's
all these you know
hoops to jump through um many many
people make it difficult for other
people to vote
um and and you know we're kind of an
unusual country in that way
on twitter my my friends from all over
the place
remark about how it just seems so
weirdly
difficult to vote in america
and and so you know people are are
definitely engaged
but they're engaged you could say to be
enraged you know rather than
really looking for a lot of solutions
and i'm painting with a broad brush here
right
there are many people out there who are
solution
oriented who are looking to work with
other reasonable people but
it seems it feels like those people
and i count myself as one of them are
are in the minority
you know at this point in time
maybe that's well go ahead as count me
down as one of those people that are
very much for i would
prefer to have boring politics politics
that are
not constantly in my face and trying to
uh induce rage in me i feel like this
yeah uh constant drum beat of like
almost political warfare yeah is not
good for the well-being of basically
anyone in this country except for those
who are
directly profiting off of it yeah you
know um
politics in part is about deliberation
and deliberation
is a rational function we're supposed to
you know you know the way that the
political system
has worked even taking america out of
the picture but
thinking about classical political
theory you've got competing interests
you've got people who have different
perspectives and they still have to live
in one society whether it's a greek
city-state
or an empire or pick whatever else you
want
they have to find some way to live
together and to not
you know be at each other's throats and
to get some basic things done the
aqueducts need to run
somewhere right somebody has to pay for
that that sort of stuff and so there's a
lot of
decisions that that do need to be made
and
deliberation is one of the things that
we can do as human beings that
raises us from the level of the mere
animals
and i think you're right that's been
short-circuited in a lot of cases
it's it's almost as if instead of having
rational persuasive appeals um
the emphasis is on just let's let's push
everybody's buttons as much as we can
you know it's almost as if it's um the
extension
of the election to constant election
yes that's right yeah yeah
that that you know instead of okay we
have a point where we're going to choose
leaders
and they are going to rationally
deliberate for the good of all the
people in the country
and try to mix these competing interests
of these
disparate groups but we still are all
under one umbrella
it has turned into a constant cat fight
for
you know you know either two four or six
year
intervals depending on the election yeah
you know
again to compare america to other
countries quite a few other places
specify when you can actually run
so like in british politics you can't
you can't run for two years before
you're actually
being elected i forget exactly what it
is but it's not a long time
you know and it'd be awesome if we
actually had stuff like that
there's so many ways i mean we could do
an entire
sequence on the so many different ways
in which um
our democratic processes have been
subverted but going back to that issue
of alienation that you were talking
about i think that's part of what makes
a lot of people feel despondent and
in in some ways that raises the stake of
well this is the one time you get to
vote so
you better get your vote in and make
sure that it happens
but you know most the rest of the time
we're not voting and
we we might be registering our views by
actually like calling or emailing or you
know tweeting out to
a representative um it's debatable how
much they actually
pay attention or care depend we can
we'll talk about gerrymandering in a
minute and why had that that's
that's alienating but um i think a lot
of people feel kind of shut out
of the political process and and you
know what you were saying with
having um so many people for each
representative
you're probably not going to get to talk
to your representative you're going to
get to talk to somebody who's
on their staff and then maybe if what
you have to say is important enough
they'll kick it upstairs
unless you've got some juice and i think
this is one of the big
issues as well it's not just that people
who are
wealthy and can make campaign
contributions get get the ears more
often not just of
you know republicans but also democrats
this is clearly an equal opportunity
thing but you know um corporations do it
as well
and you know since citizens united
corporations can
spend whatever they like and it's it's
considered to be free speech on their
part
we i think because of these sorts of
things the ordinary person
comes to feel like well their voice
doesn't matter very much and that that
is alienating
so you know either it's like the stakes
are super high and you better vote
if you don't vote you're letting
everybody down but your vote doesn't
really
count for all that that much i mean in
this this election
in some places it could you know like if
you're in
wisconsin or michigan uh
but if you live in but if you were in
yeah california kentucky or california
exactly
exactly so uh and and also you know
when we when we look at well let's talk
about gerrymandering i think that's
that's something
quite important we probably have to
define that because some people don't
don't know what it is and we didn't say
it isn't that a type of salamander
yeah it's the movement it makes as it
wobbles around
i was gonna say we didn't say it in the
sufficiently uh
disapproving tone of voice for everyone
to know that it's a bad thing right
yeah but gerrymandering it really is
yeah it's it's it's terrible it's it's
and wisconsin is one of the worst states
for it
we actually had a case unfortunately
turned down by the supreme court
uh where they could have done something
about it and
it produces these these results i mean
we were joking around before the show
about one
one of the legislative districts that
spans a couple different cities and
saying
wow these this doesn't make any sense
it's nice that the candidate won but
what did they what are they actually
reigning over you know
and so we you know it's not just a
problem for wisconsin north carolina's
also egregiously gerrymandered and
there's all sorts of other places that
in texas and what it leads to is really
bad
political representation because it
creates all these safe seats
for people who you know
if you live in that district the
republicans are going to win or the
democrats are going to win and that's
all there is to it you know
unless there's somebody really screws up
and you know for somebody like myself uh
an independent
it's even worse because you know our
votes
essentially count for for nothing
against the the mass of whatever
you know whether it's red or blue has
been put in there
for for the district and you know i i
can see how a lot of people would feel
like while the fix is in
my vote doesn't matter my voice doesn't
matter i think i think it's not just
their vote i think it's that they feel
that
um no matter what they what what they do
it's not going to make any real
difference
so that's a little alienation right
yeah it is like quintessential
alienation this
thing that we are supposedly
participating in
our our democracy our our political
process
in which we give the voice to the people
to at least
elect our representatives and in some
states we have even direct democracy
with a
binding referendum that changed the laws
directly
um that you know if if you don't feel
that uh because the way the rules
were drawn up that you can't ever win
like why why would anyone have any
incentive to actually go out
and play the game yeah and you know it's
not just that you can't
win which is bad enough by itself
because you can't win
nobody has to listen to you nobody has
to pay attention to what you have to say
you know your representative is like
well
who are you why do i care you know and i
i think this also kind of figures in
you know think about the recent
presidential elections going back a ways
by the time that it gets around here to
wisconsin the primaries are you know
pretty far along you know we're not in
super tuesday we don't really have much
of a
a choice in deciding like who's going to
go on to the big leagues and
and actually like engage in the primary
contest
uh that is the the national election
and so you know it's easy to get a
little bit disheartened about that
and to say well you know we're stuck
with what this party
puts forward and what this party puts
forward um there's there's all of you
know
that sort of issue and then there's you
know the incredible role that
donations and and money plays in that
so even if you did belong to a political
party
um other than ultimately being told well
get behind the candidate
um whoever that happens to be that
somebody else has selected
you don't really have that much role to
play it feels like in a lot of cases and
you know sometimes you get candidates
that you can feel strongly about and be
like yeah i really like this person
that hasn't been the case most of the
time in my experience
and i think there's there's also groups
that get you know really taken
for granted by both parties
and they don't get they don't get very
well treated
by by the parties and that that also
would be alienating you know this
expectation that
what are you going to do you're going to
you're going to vote for the other party
and show us you know yeah and
so a potential solution not that i'd say
a panacea for this particular portion of
the alienation would be
something along the lines of an instant
runoff where you say like okay here
here are my like here are all the
candidates and i can rank them one to
ten
yeah say if there are ten and um this
way i can say like oh
like sam i'm very i'm libertarian
like i i voted for joe and then
and then my next preference might be
trump or something and on the way down
and so the whole idea is that you know
whoever uh has the least amount of votes
on the first round they they get dropped
off the ballot and all their
votes are then reapportioned to the next
candidate
whatever their number twos were and so
this allows you to say okay
i'm not throwing my vote away i'm still
putting out this is the person that i
would most prefer
but just because i choose this person as
my bose for
uh uh preferred yeah that's the word um
that doesn't mean that i can't also say
if that person does not make it then
this would be my next preference and
that also gives you this uh feeling that
the people that actually win it instead
of having a first pass to post where you
can have a
person that wins with you know less than
50 winning the election
um that you always have someone that has
a
majority winning election yeah
they call that ranked choice voting
right i think in some other places
ranked choice or instant runoff it's
very i think they're
interchangeable i think there's a state
and i'm blanking on which one it is
that actually has that oh right right
yeah
and and i mean that would that i i would
think that would be uh good that would
produce more participation and
maybe better well better thought out
voting on the part of a lot of people
you know
um but uh
yeah that i don't see that as as likely
to get passed in too many places do you
no because the the incumbent parties
it makes sense for them to be against
that
yeah you know so this is not something
that we were actually going to talk
about but i think this also fits in with
the alienation thing as well so we're
kind of caught in a bind
because putting aside the the massive
partisanship
and divides between you know liberals
and conservatives
and you know republicans and democrats
on so many things
you're right they do kind of all come
together in
making sure that nothing is really going
to be different
going forward as far as how things are
done you know i
we were talking before this about how
some
um you know some of my colleagues
outside of the united states they look
at what we go through with the electoral
college and they're like why don't you
why don't you move away from that why
don't you get rid of that
and then we say you know if we could we
would but
do you understand how difficult it would
be to change it
you would have to have a constitutional
amendment and then they say well that
doesn't sound so hard why don't why
don't you do that
and then you say well take a look at
what it requires
what what sort of consensus you have to
build
in order to get that and so on the one
hand there's no way that you're going to
bring everybody together and get them to
agree to that
just because of the factionalization
that we have and how divided people are
and how distrustful they are of the
other side
even if you could though they'd be like
well this goes directly against our
interest why the hell would we do that
why would we open the door to
having things you know more uh you know
participational this is a terrible idea
and unfortunately we're stuck with all
of these people as
our rulers and our representatives
and to get rid of all of them at one
fell swoop would be very difficult to
even imagine let alone pull off so we're
kind of stuck with it and that
i think this the cumulative effect of
this is
that that people feel despondent they
they feel disengaged they feel like i am
going to go and vote because i i want to
make a statement but then
what happens what happens after that
what what what what did your political
will actually
accomplish it's almost like a sisyphean
task right pushing the boulder up the
hill
and then it just falls down on the other
side and and you you
push it up again and you at a certain
point sisyphus has to say man
this is bs why am i doing this
but if we if we do that then that
doesn't work either right it's almost
this is a real conundrum because if we
disengage totally from voting
then other people's votes count and
and and ours don't at all and then we
get perhaps even worse outcomes
yeah that that little monochrome of
um not power but like uh
agency yeah determine things yeah
yeah uh so
so why why shouldn't we just like you
know force a a perfect monoculture and
um make sure that everyone um just
thinks the same way here
wouldn't that make everything just
better well i mean trying to do that in
a multicultural society is
is very difficult anyway but i i think
that would that would
be a bad bad approach
i mean there are a lot of people who are
like i just want everyone to shut up i i
i don't want any more of this argument
right just pick something and stick to
it
um that's not a very rational way to
to get good outcomes right i mean part
of why we want democratic processes is
so we can take
different perspectives into view
and and hear from other people and and
have them
represented and you know i think once
you start talking about
like having unity imposed on people
um it sounds like some sort of
totalitarianism or you know fascist
approach to things and those have been
tried they're they almost never work
uh the way that they're well
yeah even in the short term they impose
a lot of cruelty and brutality upon
people but they also
they're pragmatically they don't work
you know they wind up
ruining their economies and um getting
themselves into stupid military
adventures and getting people killed off
and
um i i think we can say that there's
been sort of a historical verdict
on those i mean we do have arguably
fascist or totalitarian
totalitarian light we'll call them at
this point governments that have
arisen within recent years that we can
point to but i don't think their
long-term prospects are particularly
good
it reminds me of um star wars and
oh princess leia talking to darth vader
saying
the more you tighten your grip lord
vader the more star systems slip through
your grasp
yeah i mean what do you make of that i
mean do you think that really works that
way or
um well it's either they slip or they
like you you crush them out i know
yeah and and you you get conformity
prevent
you you get a conformity but you also
you destroy the spark that like
moves a lot of modern economies as well
as
like who wants to live in that drudgery
yeah and
constant fear of potential death yeah
that's that's a good point imposing some
sort of
um absolute across-the-board orthodoxy
usually it doesn't just like stop you
know innovation in the sense of like you
know
things in in the tech sector i mean it
does it across the board
it it destroys the spirit of of people
so yeah politics business philosophy
the universities science yeah like if it
doesn't fit within the
perfect confines that have been defined
by the ruling class
then it becomes you know outside of the
bounds and
anyone who's doing that becomes persona
not greta
yeah i mean you gotta you gotta push
pretty hard sometimes to actually get
yourself in trouble in some of those
institutions but some people manage to
do it anyway
you know and then and then there's all
sorts of irrational inequities as well
i was just reading something so this is
a little bit off topic but it's
something i'm going to
uh i'm thinking about posting and it had
to do with
student evaluations so this person
did an experiment and you could do it
because it was an online class
and they created an avatar and persona
for themself
one being female one being male
different names different pictures that
were being used and then they interacted
as the same ta with all of these
students it was a big class it was like
you know 200 students or so and then
at the end of the semester they had
evaluations and the evaluations for the
female presenting um
person that the ta were significantly
worse than they were for the male
and and we know that this is the case in
in student evaluations and
and you know it's an irrational thing
it's not i mean
i can tell you that just looking at
evaluations of some of my female peers
they're not teaching worse than
male teachers are that the bar is pretty
low for most of the male teachers
already
and we can do a whole show on
that right i will concur on that yeah
and and uh so it's clearly because of
some sort of bias or
you know and and so there's inequities
like that and those don't get addressed
very often you know
there's there's inequities like that
based on on race in our society
um classism plays a huge role
you know so when we when we could go
back to this like
let's impose some solution from on high
it almost never fixes those things
adequately you know um what we need
is is much more lower level
fixing things like on the ground
changing things
as as individuals and in our
relationships but also in political ways
but maybe we could say in locally
political ways
and if there's going to be something
coming in from up on high
maybe it's got to interface with those
things adequately
you know
yeah so uh moving on from
uh totalitarianism
i guess hopefully yeah yeah
um so what was your your
thoughts on like the difference from
2016 to now
you know um 2016
if you think about how the candidates
were selected
um in the primary season
it was really quite different than than
this one on the democrat side we had you
know like an
heir apparent hillary clinton who had
you know
put in her time sort of like how john
mccain had been in the previous
uh election cycles um you know
uh mccain got to be the candidate after
after bush because he'd been in there
and he'd done all these
sort of things and i think clinton kind
of thought that you know and a lot of
her her backers thought that it was kind
of owed to her
and there was really only one other
candidate
um that was worth noticing and that was
bernie sanders and he's
he's you know a very interesting person
but kind of an outlier
he he was able to get a movement going
that that could you know last into this
election cycle as well
um but you know he is an independent who
caucuses with with
uh democrats and and so on that side it
was like well the
you know there'll be an election
there'll be a primary season
um but a lot of people kind of felt like
the fix was in
and there wasn't an awful lot of
enthusiasm i think for
clinton as a candidate and then we had
the weirdness of the republican thing
with all these different candidates
you know for the first time we had to
have like you know separate debates
because they couldn't all be on the
stage at the same time
and we get this this at that time you
know
crazy uh nutty uncle
trump um somehow making it through
all of these these things i mean what we
know now what he did was he mobilized a
lot of
um aspects of american life that had
been there in the tea party
and that he could appeal to like like
you know racism
and it turned out that that was that was
quite a potent message and then he could
also
like just say things that were insulting
to other candidates say we
you know ted making fun of ted cruz's
wife for example
um making fun of his father calling
marco little marco
you know marco rubio and and uh just all
sorts of crazy the stuff that
people were like can you believe this
guy you know
how is he gonna survive the next like
challenge to him
and he kept on like blowing through it
sort of like a mr magoo
you know of of politics and
all these other like traditional
candidates i mean think about jeb bush
you know
um he was the front runner and he just
disappeared
that was the end of his class his
political career right
so so you've got these two candidates
the guy who's
um you know claiming that he's is the
successful businessman
doesn't appear to like be able to hold
the thought very long
you know people are kind of wondering
about him and then you've got
hillary clinton running as well not
running here in wisconsin
as as we know right and and there's the
alienation once again
exactly yeah yeah and then and you know
people did also vote for libertarians or
for greens and
uh there was also the constitution party
at the time
um and you know so and interestingly
i mean uh turnout was up we can say um
so that's kind of a good thing and then
we had you know the midterms and turnout
was pretty good for these these midterms
as well people are getting more
interested in politics
but they seem to be getting like we said
before they're they're interested in
politics in part because they're like we
can't let those
sobs win you know right um
and i i don't know go ahead oh yeah just
the
idea of like if your politics are screw
the other guy
then like yeah why are you in this
place where like politics and consensus
and you know rational debate are
something that we
obsessively actually care about or just
do we not anymore
yeah well that's the thing is if enough
people don't care about it and are more
into it to
um what's what's the meme version of it
to
um not to own the other people but to
and not to enrage them i'm blanking at
it right now
um you know to to provoke the
the other side um i mean that's not
that's not a
that's not a viable political platform
that's not gonna get anything done and
um
yeah i i think if there's if there's too
much of a critical mass of that
then we're we're in deep trouble and
then if you're one of the people who
wants to see some sort of rational
politics and consensus that would be
quite quite dismaying
yeah very disheartening yeah and
but i think we do have a little bit of
light at the end of the tunnel because
we're going to actually use a little bit
of our philosophy to deal with how to
deal with these things before we get to
that though
let me let me i just thought of this let
me
bounce a question off of you so
this was an election where nobody really
got what they wanted
i mean nobody really got what they
wanted from the primary
season and and
i i think there's even plenty of people
uh in
in the conservative and republican camp
who are like yeah i mean
this guy i don't i don't know that we
really you know he
we we voted for him back in 2016 but
he's he's a hot mess and
i don't know that he's exactly what we
want for the the party
right i mean they're happy that he got
them the judges that they wanted but
that was that was basically it judges
and tax cuts you know
before he he pushed ryan out of the the
uh
the whole leadership yeah basically the
whole party right
wisconsin has done terribly by the way
in terms of its
republican political leadership we lost
ryan we lost priebus
they just got swallowed up by this
administration but but going back to
this right
so this is an election where nobody
really got what they wanted
unless what you were is a centrist who
loves gridlock
and loves people fighting with each
other
would it be better if we'd had like a
dramatic
republican victory or a dramatic
democratic victory like let's say
let's make it something like this and
this is kind of a comic book
sci-fi kind of situation they win the
presidency
they they win a majority of the
senate and they win it in such a way
that they've got 60 seats
and they win you know a vast majority of
the house of representatives let's say
they got like 300 representatives
right so you've got like a clear
domination of not just the presidency
but the whole legislative branch
whether it's republican or democrat
would that have been a better outcome
than this messy
now we have to figure out what what our
way forward is going to be even though
we all hate each other
at this point is it is it better to have
like a
you know an absolute like here's the
people who won now everybody else
shut up and and get with the program
what do you think
i guess it depends on who you're at who
you are and so i think
like right now i think the large
corporations
love this outcome because there's going
to be gridlock and there's very little
chance that
big change will happen which usually
costs
them money or they have to innovate out
of it to deal with the new political
realities
um
that's actually that's a great point
though not only do they like it because
of that
they like it because then they can keep
still funneling money to both parties
and getting the results that they want
right
right right absolutely um but i guess
my personal like political proclivities
seem to be that some of the
policy positions i think are really
necessary for
you know a more perfect union a
world that has uh more flourishing in it
um are only being represented by one
party
and i guess from a personal position i
think like it would
it requires that at least in the the
political landscape that we're currently
in um but do i think that's good
i don't know like it i guess if
if it was actually the will of the
people that everyone was actually like
hey look like for the most part
we're all going in this direction yeah
um i would say i'd be like rather happy
with that because not only is it
what personally i think it would be
better results in better policy
but i also it's not like me or or
the people that i'm with forcing the
issue on
on to someone and and causing extra
alienation that way
but that it's it's you know politically
popular and people want to do it
yeah yeah that makes that makes sense um
it's i mean it's interesting that there
are some things that i think you and i
could probably find some common ground
on and say i i you know this is this is
this policy represents a certain ethical
stance
a right way of approaching things like
not letting people think about health
care right our health care system is a
total mess
so many people fall through the the
cracks even if even if you're like
totally that should all be free market
it's not a free market it's a it's
it's just a a mess and you you compare
us to other countries and
you see that they do have universal
health care it's not perfect but it
sure is way better than what we've got
right now and it's a nice thing to have
during a pandemic too
um so don't get me on to asymmetric
knowledge problems
yeah well yeah there's that could be
another show too right
it could be all different variants of
that that would be that would actually
be a good topic but
so we we could say that um this this
would be a good policy to get through
and and it's it's probably not going to
get through
due to gridlock and um even if it's like
a paired down version
and it gets pushed through if it's if
it's very unpopular
then it can become this you know like
this
canker essentially you know like the the
affordable care act
um that i'll tell you you know we we use
it because we're small business people
and uh thank god for it because
otherwise we wouldn't have medical
treatment
for all the things that we need to do
and we pay a still a good bit of money
uh in the marketplaces and it's not you
know perfectly efficient or anything
like that but you know that that has
become a bone of contention
for so many people on the conservative
side they just they want to kill it no
matter what right and then other people
are like oh we've gotta
gotta stop them from killing it and my
question to them is always how are you
gonna make it
better so it actually does what it's
supposed to do and then they just look
at me like i'm stupid
right but you know when if we did have
a a clear majority on the
the blue side maybe we would be able to
push through things like that
uh which we which we're definitely going
to have to do sooner or later i mean
things can't go on
this way permanently there are some
some things that we probably could just
keep kicking down
down the road but i don't know that this
is one of those you know
figuring out what to do about student
loan debt that's probably another one we
can't keep kicking down the road forever
right
right so yeah we really need to
talk about philosophy phil's philosophy
yeah and basically
like some of the strategies that we can
employ
in order to you know have a little bit
more equanimity in our lives
uh you know tranquility in our thoughts
and so
so one of them is yeah well before we do
that
um what if somebody was to object wait a
second
in this terrible you know screwed up
political situation who
are you to have equanimity you know uh
aren't you like carving out your own
little
private space for yourself you you
privileged person
you know how can you not care about how
bad things are i mean
i think there's a good response to that
and i think you have a good response to
that as well right
yeah if just because there are
trials and tribulations and bad things
happening within the world
on doesn't mean that you can't find your
own equanimity
as well as it is really important for
you to have a
at least a monochrome of equanimity in
order to actually
uh go out and produce actions that
result
in better outcomes in the world you say
like oh there's all these things going
and everything that's on fire
it's like well if i'm here and i'm going
ah and running around in circles
it helps nothing it doesn't help me it
doesn't help them i need to have some
center in order to actually go out and
help them
yeah i think that's that's a that's a
great response and it also
you know kind of models what we want to
be moving towards we can't all be like
uh engaging in in you know crisis
actions all the time that's that's not a
life
you know that's that's a that's
something that sometimes we have to do
to preserve a life but
i i don't think that that's something
that we want so i think that's a great
response that that makes perfect sense
hopefully listeners who are enraged at
us for
uh suggesting that we should carve out a
little time and space for
ourselves apart from you know constantly
being engaged in politics uh we'll we'll
hear it that way too
[Laughter]
um so one of the things you can do is
you can employ some historical
perspective
um you know avoid making these usually
wrong and easy analogies um
about like the actual enormity of the
the perceived
bad that we're in you know like um
look at like the fall of empires or the
sacking of cities or
you know plagues that are worse than the
plague that we're currently in
like the black death that killed 36 of
the population of europe
it's like we're right now because of our
really good health system you know covet
is only down to
what one or two percent death rate at
least in the united states
um you know think of like half of
everyone that you know
dying and like that really puts it in
perspective like we we've made it
through that as a species in the past
and we can
make it through this yeah i think
that could also lend itself to somebody
going
too far with that point of view and
saying oh well see if it's not as bad as
the black death it's not really bad
you know but i think some some
historical
you know the answer to like misusing
historical
perspective is let's get even more
historical perspective i think
and you know you might say well that's
history that's not philosophy
well you know since the 19th century
philosophy has at least certain kinds of
philosophy been very much about
cultivating historical perspective
you know and we could even say that this
is something that was around before you
know
marcus aurelius in his meditations
suggests we should do exactly what you
were saying think about the fall
i don't know if you remember mentioned
the falls of empires but you certainly
talked about the sacking of cities right
how all these things happen over and
over again
and you know the human race still
continues on
um it's not the absolute end of the the
world although it may be the end of a
political regime
yeah and then you know the next thing as
we're talking about earlier
gaining a little equanimity in order to
actually focus on what
really is in your control that what you
can actually do
to materially or mentally affect the
well-being of those people around you
that you
like want to do good for
yeah and and you know i think it's
important to be realistic in the amount
of good that we can
we can do um for one thing
anything political if it involves other
people they might say no to us
they might use our our efforts and then
not
not return anything on the investment of
time and energy and
even emotion that we've made but that's
that's not
our problem that's in a certain respect
that's them just being
not so great people it didn't it didn't
mean that everything that we did was
totally in vain
um you know everybody who went around
canvassing
i i saw people too you know saying oh
man i spent all this money you know
supporting candidates you know sending
in these these
contributions and these are people who
didn't have a lot of money to begin with
um oh it was all wasted no it wasn't it
wasn't wasted
it just didn't accomplish what it was
that you hoped for it to accomplish
and and so having a better perspective
on that can make one feel less
i don't know angry or sad or
you know upset i would say it's really
at least within stoke posse one of the
big things is that you don't
want to put your desire in the outcomes
of things but in doing the right things
well yeah um and so just because
the outcome didn't have the outcome that
you wanted
was going out there and trying to
advocate for your position
not the good thing to do in the time
just because it didn't
have the exact outcome that you wanted
that's actually a great point you know
um you think about like canvassing or
um being on a phone or text bank
and getting you know responses from
people like screw you
your candidate's awful you know um
interestingly epictetus when he's
talking about the philosopher's socrates
who the the stoics looked at is kind of
like a
they thought if anyone's going to be a
sage probably socrates was
epictetus said socrates had about a one
in one thousand success rate
you know maybe one person out of a
thousand that he talked to actually
changed their life for the better it
doesn't mean that he
that he was wasting his time all that
time
he was actually doing a good thing you
don't you don't control what other
people do with the
message and if you can say that then
things become
less high stakes right so if i want to
convince you that you made
a bad voting decision and you should
vote differently next time you and i can
have a conversation
and i can pursue it up to a certain
point and you can say hey listen you're
not going to convince me and i can say
okay let's put the ideas out there you
know food for thought for you
that's probably much more likely to be
successful than if i keep on pushing
stuff down your throat
you know and because then you're like
that guy and those people
you know they're they're they're awful
that way so sometimes
by um using these these techniques or
insights that do help us to
have equanimity um we can actually be
more effective
so like there are lots of interesting
techniques
in persuasion there's a big like topic
within
a psychology and philosophy of like what
what is
actually good persuasive technique yeah
and
and almost never will you get someone
like oh yes
i've now seen the lights i'm going to
change my entire life
because i've changed this pillar of my
entire being and like
from a long time a single philosophical
argument you mean
yeah yeah that never happens
there there are certain things that
people kind of rest their personalities
on and their
the world view that they live in and
um and they're they
protect these ideas like they protect
their body from harm
and it's actually interesting there's
been studies on
what portions of the brain light up when
someone is uh
has one of their core values um
be criticized criticized or poked out
with a good argument and it it
results in the same area of the brain
that uh results from like
oh i shouldn't touch the hot stove
because your brain's like
i need to save that portion of my brain
that is that is really important to me
it's gonna cause me a lot of pain
if i lose that um as well as you get
things like the backfire effect where
people
who are presented with information that
directly contradicts an idea
and they actually if you don't do this
well if you're just like
you should say do this and you throw a
whole bunch of facts to them yeah often
you'll have a point where they actually
believe that position
even more on which is yeah
kind of crazy it's very interesting but
you know there are
techniques out there um there's a group
on the internet
that does what they call street
epistemology where they yeah talk
about what that actually is because i've
heard about that and i don't really
understand that that well
okay so epistemology is the um
the way how you know things um
in a really simple way of putting it and
so street epistemology is a way of
having conversations and the the point
of the conversation
is to exit the conversation with both
people
enjoying that they've had the
conversation um
and so you're you're never gonna like be
trying to like trigger someone or
attack their core values you're
you're asking okay you hold a position
that um you usually hold very strongly
and
usually it's a best if you're talking
about a position that makes you
change your actions in the real world
um and then you ask them
why do you believe that is true how did
you come to that conclusion
and and a lot of times people have bad
reasons you know add populum uh yeah
you know just because that's how they
grow up grew up and that's the ideas
that their parents
told them there's all these things and
they're they're not
logically sound and so that that's a
really good way to get people
not to the aha moment but a moment and
the
moments are the like the really good
ones because it's like oh
once you're in whom you're like i am in
a position where i might be
willing to learn you know the the flip
side of that
is so if you are presenting something
that's
an alternative to what what they think
and not necessarily as
you know like a a total package but just
at least some
some alternative ways of thinking about
it they're more likely to be willing to
consider it if you haven't been a jerk
to them
in the the conversation right so they
can not only and it's not just about
well i don't like how that person made
me feel
it's also about you representing a
reasonable person who sees things
somehow
differently and then they can think what
what's going on there
i mean that person seems to be normal in
other respects and yet they
they hold this position i don't i don't
know maybe i have to look into that
position a bit more
you know so
um well we should talk about the the
practice that we wanted to
close on because we're getting close to
the end of the the show
yeah so um go ahead
so in this time where people might be
fine like okay well now what like the
election's over
and and i've been so engrossed in this
this giant you know pageantry for the
last
what feels like two years forever on
are two years going on forever yeah but
you
find some practice that will either
mentally materially make your life
better and then set an implementation
intention to set it in motion
and so an implementation intention is
basically an if
if then statement so for example if i
said
i wanted to make a um a change and like
improve my health a little bit i'm going
to take up jogging and so i
say if i wake up in the morning then
i'm going to put on my shoes and go for
a three mile run and it
helps even better if you put your shoes
right in front of your
bedroom door in the morning so you can't
even open your door without
having to move those shoes that's even
better but the idea is to
to make a um a plan
that's usually an if then statement and
either
say it to yourself out loud or write it
down and that seems to
um really improve the outcomes of
actually doing it and
and hopefully the outcome here is that
you're going to
have some sort of practice you know what
is meditation or
exercise or i don't know reading a good
book or
reaching out to a friend who you haven't
talked to for a while
yeah or having a better more substantive
conversations
in a uh constructive sense and not an
adversarial sense yeah now why why is
this a good practice to get into
well you've already hit on part of it
it's going to improve your life in some
some manner but it also helps to
distract you
from all the turmoil and
partisanship that we we've gone through
and and put some new ideas into your
head
you know focus on something else for a
change
and you could actually like say okay
every time that i'm tempted to like
look at an opinion poll i'm going to do
this instead
or at least i'm going to think about the
thing that i'm changing instead
[Music]
and you don't want to get ruminating
about all these political things and
like it's just
spinning in your mind's eye but i think
we need to leave you today
with the words mark twain loyalty to
country
always loyalty to government when it
deserves it
[Music]
you